just going by Honda Accord yes
intellects on cars because I went back
if it was Kia sponsoring your show I
just keep my mouth shut I don't want you
to lose business
no you look the point is you the Accord
excellent time you say what you mean I
do
now the Accord by the way yes who needs
more than an accord I think you work
towards an accord and what you hit a
chord you stop mm-hmm I think of course
is goodness in your ear if you're as a
matter of fact yes I'm gonna be honest
hearing this I think my next car is
gonna be in a court you know why I'm
predicting to have an all-electric
accord by then you think so yeah well
you put the pressure on yeah well you
put the pressure I'm sure they're
feeling the end well right down the road
here in Torrance California can you get
a sweater like that in Torrance
[Laughter]
nothing against it I'm Pro mob sweater
for all of my gay friends because it
looks right on a gay man a game see it's
a gay sense of style that looks right
okay and it works are you wearing
loafers hi no no I'm wearing some sort
of the owl that those are just wrong I
hate this way bowling shoes no laces at
all the way they're so they're the best
where's mr. Brockman dude I know I mean
what's up good to see you buddy yes yes
you may I want your listeners to know
hmm okay that he dates a woman that is a
very close friend of mine yes and when I
was on I had mentioned it once but I got
some Intel he is supposedly a great
great boyfriend she started telling me
all the things that he does for her and
I thought this man is smart okay because
she's a great woman not a good woman a
great woman and she's gorgeous and she's
just she is awesome she is I've been
friends with her for years
and she is awesome and I am so happy
they're together but she just I just had
was with her the other day I know and
she was just going
and what a great boyfriend he is she
tried to get him to wear mauve he said
hold on a second yeah you're talking
about Sarah Tiana the you came on you
came on here about two years ago and
you're like I'm hearing or you said I've
got the perfect girl for you yeah
did you set them up no okay okay she
asked me if I knew you and I was like
yeah I go that could be great you took a
long time take a long time yeah yeah cuz
he's he's screwed up in the head what
did you hear this I'm do you got it
together so yeah he and I are not
wearing mom but you're way more together
than we are rich you are so far advanced
as a man beyond what we are I'm evolved
yes except with your sweaters what what
did you hear specifically that bethi's
that he's very different for example
she's she's a bit of comedian she she
works really hard just shall play some
crap past town should be very lonely who
flies in and surprises there were you
surprised you've you've flown in and
surprised I've done it a couple times
yes where San Francisco Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh we were City to there for the
Hall of Fame yeah but point being is
your listeners to know a great boyfriend
to a great woman like he's got a great
woman and he knows it and he knows it so
I mean we're learning it all about him
we learned this week his favorite movies
you've got mail that is wrong that's
equivalent to wearing a mauve sweater
not favorite just I like I like to
rewatch it a lot reward your favorite
movie Lawrence of Arabia for example
I'll watch over and over we have we have
a segment here that we've we've called
start bench cut where we give you three
items yes start one bench one and cut
what sort of like you know that the [ __ ]
yeah you know what the what Mary killed
okay what we could do that for you if
you want we good okay we'll set
something up and one of
in the next couple minutes I gave him
three movies his three May favorite
movies you've got mail a fugitive and
Shawshank Redemption
okay Shawshank a great movie deliver
when would you start winter cut I would
start the fugitive mm-hmm I would bench
Shawshank come to my office I'm just
gonna have him tell them just tell them
the cut so you've got mail movie there's
a story behind it though I had my
freshman year at college I like my mom
came to visit me out of the blue we went
to saw that movie in the theater
together so that kind of holds a little
spot in my heart is your mom still alive
still alive then it shouldn't hold that
died a few months ago yes I know and I
have memories of her taking lots of
movies she only wanted me to love
musicals and I wouldn't do it I don't
have any regrets Jeff Garlin here on
horizon
okay so let's do a start bench cut just
off the top start bench cut bears
all-time greats Mike Ditka Gale Sayers
Walter Payton start Walter Payton Bench
Gale Sayers cut Mike Ditka you didn't
stutter at all no that's okay um
dick is a pain in the ass man is your
coach uh yeah he's not your coach he's
fine enough with him he's just a bit
much he's and I played cards once with
Gale Sayers
and I told him that I swear I told him
this that I watched Brian's song in the
nude I might have started him but he did
not find it amusing
laughter you're joking you
although do you watch Brian Oh Brian saw
I watch all the time whatever I know
nobody I gotta clear out my contact
lenses I'm putting on Brian's son cuz
that though I'll weep okay but not in
that manner you don't watch it Nate in
it yes and I never watch it he found
nothing funny about it
I love Gale Sayers but he sees on the
bench until Peyton's hurt so and that
was during a Hold'em game I was doing a
Steve doll televised poker okay yeah it
was like a bunch of people from The
Sopranos Gale Sayers me and one or two
other Chicago people 60-second break
back more we'll talk Goldberg's we'll
talk more of these things get more of
these start bench cuts yeah those are
fun because we we were like should we do
that with Jeff make fun of stuff yes
yeah no come on okay very good we're
back in 60 seconds with Jeff will talk
Goldberg's curb and so much more in just
six
[Music]
all right welcome back to our show Joe
still here I just know count that it was
wonder well I like a good cast it was
one of those yes you know the way homers
where you get you get laugh again on the
way home I just had that in the
60-second break that when you're playing
poker with Gale Sayers
going all in one is pushing all your
chips heads up against them and you made
a mental demerit last hard at that I
might have put in laughs at all I might
have said that I can't pick a starter
between him and Payton okay we backfield
by the way yeah oh right imagine the two
of them behind you that's nuts
who would your quarterback think it
doesn't matter load up the box doesn't
matter so um you said last time we
chatted that you'd given up on the Bears
have you are you still there or you or
you or you they've made some good moves
I'm really happy with the moves they've
made so we'll see you but I'm I'm not a
pessimistic fan you know I I think that
they've made some really good move so
we'll see I'm excited mr. Biscay is
ultra brisk and I've been in on him the
whole time you happen the whole time
what do you because you know what when
you're the Bears and you stink that bad
you have to trade 40 picks for one guy
and take a chance and it certainly
looked like the Houston what's you
sistema the Texans the Texans did it all
with deshaun Watson got hurt he'll come
back and be great I'm sure but you
thought oh everyone you know but he
played like a first-year quarterback
plays Hey look Wentz was the number two
overall so I watched him play and he was
I was happy I think he's gonna be great
and now they got somebody who's big be
well they got the coach from Oregon so
they're gonna be the offensive
coordinator they're gonna bring they're
gonna bring the college run-pass option
that we're seeing that foals is now
using right to get the Eagles to the
Super Bowl they're they're gonna go
whiskey and by the way let's see in the
draft or receiver let when I visited you
in the draft yes the Bears drafted that
dude Kevin white Kevin white oh dear God
I know so the point being is we need a
receiver we need to sign a free agent
receiver then we're good to go
and tarik cohen - rico not a jew big
bowl of delight not a jew love by the
way by the way as among amongst the jews
honorary cultural jew anyhow yeah so
he's fine with making of a bagel with me
so LD was here a few months ago your
listeners please explain to low LDL
Larry David thank you he was here well I
think it would have been
self-explanatory when I I told this tell
the story that when I asked him which
quarterback you one of the Jets it's
that to take he said he will take the
[ __ ] is what he said referring to Josh
Rosen in that manner eligible to get
Josh Rosen well their sixth overall I'm
not gonna get Josh Rosen I don't think
so II know no are you a mock draft guide
do you look at mock drafts I look at
every mock draft do you really oh I'm a
big bowl of mock draft where's the draft
this year
am i coming to visit you wanna it's in
Dallas no it's like the Cubs were in the
World Series it was in Cleveland I ain't
going they didn't go to the know I had
to film the Goldbergs on the outbound
but I'm not gonna ask for timeout to fly
to Cleveland did you go to any of the
games and all the games in Chicago three
four five oh my god good night nurse but
no no we're not going to Cleveland not
gonna douse there's certain cities no
thank you
okay by the way have I played in
Cleveland you bet have I played in
Dallas you bet I talk from experience
the draft in Cleveland well yeah I mean
in chicken Dallas well you're playing
here at the Hollywood improv every week
of the show you'll probably get laid you
know what's so funny
there's no rhyme or reason to that title
they said to me what do you want to call
it I call it you'll probably get laid
and it was like in this time and the way
things are really I'd even said I don't
care about political correctness it's
all good you probably get laid and by
the way it's probably well
you might alright you could I'm not
going to but you have a good time I mean
might and could is is a is not as strong
as probably I mean yeah you're
practically guaranteeing its but you
know don't hold me but yeah yeah look if
you got the skills get laid
yeah there's always plenty of
good-looking people at my shows both
male and female all they have people
like sex all they have to do is put on
the cowboy hat right oh yeah well that
was one of my favorite moments of the
past
I enjoyed wearing the cowboy hat yes I
have it I have it can have the cowboy
should have worn it tonight it wasn't
bad I keep all my wardrobe how absurd is
that you in the cow it fits very nicely
maybe I'll wear it tomorrow night nice
things you should bring it to the draft
oh yeah
cuz I want to call attention to myself
the other felt drafts going on hey
everybody look at me look at the
comedian with the cowboy hat don't pay
attention
I don't need attention rich I don't wear
mauve sweaters I got people who wear a
black t-shirt I fade into the woodwork
yeah yeah now how until curbs coming
back right yeah we start filming young
April yeah so do you know what the next
season's about at all the history of
pottery it's definitely not that
no I have no idea I do know you do yeah
they have so they do have an inkling of
an idea of what it does I've already
written
Larry's already written I think seven or
eight episodes already 10 yeah have you
seen a rough draft now it's red any of
them but I know the story okay and
you're fired up for it are you gonna be
in it more I'm not fired up for the
world to be fired up you're nothing I'm
fine but if you told me there's a room
that I can go take a nice and happen
right now yes you'd see a fella get
fired up there is there is yeah the
green room here I've been and there's
not a good place for accidentally and
they wake you up I've napped on that
couch actually we are for for your show
oh yeah that's show we have five animals
coming we have an alligator yes for
while you enjoy show business
how about a blue a Blue Tongue skink
Blake Griffin wants to be a comedian I
know what do you think does he got the
chops for it
I think it's a funny dude I don't know
you haven't seen you see predict
anything anymore too many people who
suck make it
you haven't seen a set I've never seemed
you stand up no I don't even do anything
comedic Lee except to talk with him and
he's a funny affable guy but you are too
but I wouldn't face a series on
[Laughter]
utilizing show the show to be thank you
sir so let's play we have three start
bench cuts keep it away from me
someone's gotta get me can you get my
trip my americano I don't want to go
somebody to retrieve his americano to
avoid a cross pass with an alligator
can I ask most of your viewers even
though they can't answer how many of you
if you knew there was an alligator near
your coffee well go get my coffee no
start bench cut here we go first I mean
it bears vert yeah just a little bit of
a bears version if start vegetables we
do know this is a different color
Grossman Jimmy Clausen start bench cut
Oh God well I would start Grossman he
was maligned I feel he did some good
things
I would bench Cutler and cut Clausen you
bench Cutler in case Rex sexy Rexy kids
because Cutler might have a good game a
Cubs version of so very good this is
more interest Sosa grace Sandberg
Sandberg starts okay
the other two I cut
you cut we got you cut but marker I cut
my grace Mark Grace was mean to me in an
airport once he was he was very arrogant
and I didn't like him are you serious
yeah you went up to him in your life
yeah he was not he was not pleasant
she might have been drunk I'll see you
won't even benchmark grace because no I
cut him and so so please last time I saw
him I saw my reflection of the skin okay
yeah Richard Lewis JB smooth yeah Larry
David okay I okay I start Larry David JB
not so nuts Larry you know come on he's
the starter yeah what about what about
Funkhouser instead of Richard Lewis
instead of Richard Lewis same thing okay
by the way do a scene with the two of
them enjoy I couldn't love it yeah
either one of them more but I'm cutting
them I think we have one more Don give
that to me again is your plug okay here
we go
[Music]
mom lavender or periwinkle okay I start
they're all shades of purple no I know I
start periwinkle blue okay okay your
favorite Crayola crayon yeah it's a good
one
I bench lavender even though it's a
color it makes me think of the smell and
love is cut what's going on your chest
mom meets the Turk yeah that is a great
one by the way that's a good producer
get down booing okay top-notch man there
you go yeah
top notch yeah well this is fun you know
what I think every time I do
it's a long place to come for too short
so I always tease me oh go away you can
host the show yes the show never you've
never asked me you say another segment
how about that what's that you want to
stay another second oh you know
bothering please stay another segment is
this focus gonna be on me what time is
it
of course then 42 okay start bench cut
city lights Oh another segment I'm happy
to be here really and you're letting me
stay
please okay I'd love to okay Jeff Garlin
is here on the Rich Eisen show don't you
dare move one more segment with Jeff we
are back and the my pillow buy one get
one free offer still stands Jeff Garlin
oh we gotta go is my pillow put in the
promo code rich at my pillow calm after
you click on the buy one and you get a
free my pillow premium pillow after you
buy one yeah but that means that if
they're buy one you want free stuff and
what you just send me pillows about this
I'll buy the premium pillow and I'll
give you my free one how about that
you'll buy the premium that's cuz I
believe in the product that much you do
believe in the planet I'm talking about
it for two years someone should get me a
pillow my pillow comm ten year warranty
60-day money-back guarantee loves
pillows active getting a pillow he wants
to lay down and singles here's your cool
well you're talking about napping yeah
all the time let me yeah let me get you
a pillow please are you a side sleeper
you stomachs besides sleep probably got
the pillow free okay we're gonna send it
to you yep and by the way we're gonna
see the my pillow people next week
admitted there are many Minneapolis
based company so he got going on before
you go okay and wait no I love that I'm
bringing my pillow to Minneapolis I know
but you can what you can wait I'm trying
to hype up put them put the bracket up
we have we decided to do a little
bracketology in advance of our trip to
Minnesota the greatest Minnesota icon
ever we have seated individuals 1
through 16 ok Prince breathe
Bronko Nagurski and Herb Brooks beat
Dave Winfield in the Mall of America
region Jack Morris lost to F scott
Fitzgerald Paul Molitor bested Jessica
Lange these are all great Minnesotans
okay
so we'd like to for you to vote of the
boats are up right now on our yeah yeah
we got some earlier results here right
now the four seed Kevin McHale leads the
13 seed Coen brothers 53% to 47% Judy
Garland up 6040 on Joe mouth how about
that yeah would you agree with those
assessments right now Judy Garland over
Joe Malin well when I see the Wizard of
Oz I do not want to see Joe Mauer okay
and when I see the twins I do not want
to see Joe Mauer do you know Joe Mauer
what he's what what in my in my history
what he's famous for he was the reason
that the Cubs got marked prior and that
did wonders for the Cubs no kidding I
don't remember that that was the same
lineage yep and they took Mauer and then
the Cubs took priors all right so would
you also vote for Mikayla or the Coen
brothers Kevin McHale or the Coen
brothers personally on both of these I'd
book for Kevin McHale and Judy Garland
I'd vote for F scott Fitzgerald okay for
Prince I vote for the artists over the
athlete interesting yeah okay and if you
knew an alligator was nearby would you
go get your own coffee sixty-one percent
no chance
you something that makes 39 percent of
your listeners mighty weird question or
it come on you know people with coffee
and caffeine it doesn't matter if
there's an alligator they're gonna get
that damn coffee you know okay as much
as you say that
yes that's what makes sitcom so bad
because you don't take a premise like
that and do a thing on it okay like no
one would really I mean you know who's
gonna go into a room with an alligator
to get their coffee someone who wants to
die so if someone's thinking of killing
themselves that's a really kind of fun
maybe I'll do that right but in general
no okay no one's doing so to wrap things
up wait it's over already yeah that was
the boat
segment oh we got I gotta quit this show
you got time not employed here that's
right uh the Goldbergs how's your family
we're wonderful good how are you doing
I'm okay okay you're on the Goldbergs at
8:00 Eastern on a curve I'm immensely
successful as a comedian and if people
see you as a comedian at the improv then
they'll probably get get some action
yeah I met I met a club called flappers
this weekend also in Burbank and hold on
a second it's the worst name ever it's
the equivalent of the mob sweater but
don't think I don't go on stage every
time I play flappers and say what the
hell's going on with this name flappers
that's really the name why is it bass
like the 20s the flapper ladies they all
dress like that it's stupid has nothing
to do a comedy and it's really I don't
get it I asked the owners are there
every week and I say why why I don't get
it flappers floppers 19 that's why they
actually don't even mention usually that
I'm playing there I'm embarrassed but
it's a great room great room
horrible name okay that's all good the
name is the Hollywood improv the name is
go to Hollywood dot improv calm and take
it there's no tickets for this week get
them for next week this is not a lot
every week it's a small room and Jeff
Garlin invite them to your Super Bowl
party a lot of laughs yeah a party that
you want me to come to contact the Rich
Eisen show that's it or any local pillow
company that's right he'll just come
your house and watch Bruyne song by the
way that's something I do in private
yeah well not make it to private news
update Bucky Brooks in your phone calls
an hour number three I love you Jeff
girl I love you rich Eisen the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience